[Music]
I think realistically a sounding board
is a really critical part of it whether
they're talking about strategy people
management issues strategic HR do you
know what a coach could do for your
business for you this time that I have
with my client is a way to reflect
remove ourselves from the business and
try to see the forest from the trees
[Music]
welcome to season three of grit and
growth from Stanford's seat the podcast
where Africa and South Asia's Intrepid
entrepreneurs share their trials and
triumphs with insights from Stanford
faculty and Global experts on how to
tackle challenges and grow your business
[Music]
most of the entrepreneurs I know are
constantly striving to improve
themselves they devour business books
they expand their networks enroll in
classes they listen to excellent
podcasts with handsome articulate hosts
they want to be the best versions of
themselves and they want the same for
their business
but Improvement is hard to accomplish by
yourself especially when you're a busy
entrepreneur
and going it alone is like trying to
give yourself a haircut without a mirror
how are you supposed to know if you're
focusing on the right things or if
you're making progress
that's where an executive coach comes in
back in episode two we shared the story
of Kenyan business owner Kunal Raj whose
company and leadership style were
transformed through his work with a
coach our very own Lori Fuller
if you haven't had the chance go back
and listen to that one it'll pair well
with today's episode
Lori has helped dozens of businesses
like kunals all across the world each
one presents its own unique challenges
but through her work Lori has created an
arsenal of techniques to tackle
entrepreneurship's thorniest challenges
so on today's master class one of our
top business coaches shares tried and
true methods to strengthen your team
recharge your battery and help you focus
on what's truly important so my name is
Lori Fuller I am a proud coach certified
executive coach with Stanford seed based
in Nairobi Kenya and I am also active in
Venture investing Lori had an
accomplished career in the private
sector she could have easily retired but
her curiosity brought her to coaching a
few years in I realized that I really
had a passion for Learning and to be
honest Darius that really has guided all
of my choices both personal and
professional during this whole time
it's that Curiosity combined with her
experience that makes Lori such a great
coach
because I have worked with so many
different companies I can do a lot of
pattern matching and I think that this
is an undervalued skill that coaches
have I think it's just not appreciated
enough I can go into a client and I can
share best practices of other clients
anonymously of course that have faced
the same problem have had the same
people issues have had the same cultural
issues and if you're curious about so
many things how the culture operates how
the business operates in that culture
across cultures there's so many aspects
of learning and I just find personally
I'm very fulfilled when I put myself in
situations where I'm continuously
learning and challenging myself from a
growth perspective
to get the most out of coaching you have
to go in with a similar mindset that is
one of curiosity and learning and that
might be quite different than your
approach as a leader how will you know
in the after the first couple
engagements whether this relationship is
going to work and you're going to get
anywhere it's a great question so
similar to maybe the reason why a person
is a good coach because they love to
learn and they have curiosity a good
client also has those attributes I think
also they have to be comfortable with
experimentation
because if you are evolving yourself as
a leader that means that you're going to
experiment in how you act what you say
your mindset it's practicing
and so it's committing to practice how
did this go collect feedback try again
collect feedback try again so you have
to be open to the experimentation and
then you have to take the responsibility
right so I think that you're looking for
some kind of qualities and acceptance
that they're willing to go through this
journey with you and they're willing to
ask for support from others when they
need it so openness inability for
self-reflection a certain amount of
humility and courage was the last thing
I heard sounds good these qualities can
help you decide if you're even ready for
coaching the thing that's hard to
distinguish is is this coach not the
right coach for me or am I actually not
ready for coaching right that's the
self-reflection that's needed and it the
answer might be you know what I'm not
there yet this is too hard for me or
whatever and that's an honest
self-reflection too absolutely
absolutely timing is everything
so I think it is equally okay to say you
know this isn't the right time I'm not
ready and if you're distracted if
there's a lot going on in your life
whether it's personally or
professionally it just may not be a good
time because it does take a lot of
mental energy
and you want to be there and you want to
be present just like the coach is there
and present
so in your broad experience of coaching
particularly entrepreneurs whether it's
a startup or a growing business what are
some of the most common areas that
emerge that you find yourself supporting
these entrepreneurs on well I definitely
think that a sounding board is a really
critical part of it
whether they're talking about strategy
people management issues strategic HR
besides being lonely at the top
this time that I have with my client is
a way to reflect remove ourselves from
the business and try to see the forest
from the trees
and I think they very much value that
because often as a leader we get pulled
into the Urgent and we don't have time
for the important
we can protect that time together to
make that the important the big picture
and to really think deeply through
questions through discussion what that
would look like not only for the leader
on their leadership Journey but also for
the company I love that putting aside
the Urgent to focus on the important
it's just really flipping the script for
the business leader because they're like
no it's all important it's so important
I saw this is on fire it's all going to
go they go to hell tomorrow what's
interesting about that is this is a my
hypothesis you push back if this is
wrong it's a long-term job then
is to get them out of the Urgent and
build the structures and accountability
systems and build a team that allows
them to spend a lot less time on the
Urgent and a lot more time on the
important absolutely the way I often
talk about it is are they focused on the
business which is really external
strategy relationships reputation or
they focused in the business which is
all of those day-to-day tactical things
that are around the execution but the
question is the execution of what the
execution to what end
one of the most essential things a coach
can offer is perspective coaches we
expose blind spots
and we allow that space for reflection
and the way that we do that often is
holding up the mirror
so that they can look at themselves and
have an honest assessment of what
they're doing well
what they're not doing well and where
there's an opportunity for improvement
because the understanding has to come
from within them Lori has an exercise
for that as you'll find out Lori has an
exercise for pretty much everything
interestingly enough when I work with my
clients one of the things I always start
with Darius is how do I spend my time
and I asked them for two to three weeks
to track their activities and then I
have a Blog that gives an approximation
of you know 40 percent of your time as a
CEO or entrepreneur should be spent in
this area
etc etc now the percentages can be
slightly changed but what's so
interesting is that when we talked
before they do the tracking they think
they're spending their time on certain
things
and then after they do the tracking they
realize oh my gosh this isn't what I
thought at all I have this sneaking
suspicion I should do this exercise
myself well I'll send it along and we
can debrief before and after don't worry
it's free I won't charge
[Music]
often Lori encounters heroic leaders and
while that might sound like a good thing
heroic leaders can actually hurt their
own business by trying to save the
company all by themselves
rather than facilitating discussion and
empowering team members these leaders
make unilateral decisions and that
mindset can manifest in unexpected ways
I'll give you an example of something
that perhaps entrepreneurs don't realize
I'm listening for and that is language
so one of the things that can be said is
Beware of the evil letter i
it's not just what you're saying but
it's how you're saying it and if you're
a heroic leader that is micromanaging
and not delegating and wants to control
everything
I the coach will know because you are
using the word I or the letter I all the
time well I should have done that I
didn't do it I did this I hit these
goals I didn't hit these goals so I had
a client and I said do you have your
2023 plan
I don't have it well why not well I
don't have it because I set the goals
for last year and then I didn't meet
them and so I just I have a mental block
I can't do it and I said did you realize
that it's not just about you it's about
your business and perhaps one of the
reasons why your goal wasn't achievable
is because you didn't think about it
from a business capability and capacity
perspective
so whenever a client says I
I asked them can you stop in the moment
and do you really mean I me or do you
mean we and if you mean we and you
change and say we that helps us change
our mindset to it's a team I am part of
a team I am part of the company which
changes your behaviors changes your
actions and so my recommendation to this
client was is 2023 the year of we
[Music]
leadership you've got to learn to
delegate but that's easier said than
done when we think about something as a
bottleneck it's literally the neck of a
bottle right it's at the top and so
often a key opportunity for us working
with a client is to help them understand
that when it's a young company you as
the leader can delegate things that you
don't like to do
things you're not interested in things
that drain your energy but when you
become larger then if you're really
focused on the business which is your
role then you end up having to delegate
things that you might be good at and you
may think you're the best one in the
company to be doing it but not now not
in this role and so the risk actually in
delegation the blind spot you have to
look for is that you may put your
company at risk
in the area that you think you are best
suited to do so I think there was one
example where the founder very much
wants to be in the lead facilitate
everything to make sure that we get the
right answer from our team the right
answer meaning the answer that he
already had in his mind exactly yes
right answer in quotes right I already
know what the answer is but I've been
told that I need to get input from the
team because that's best practice so let
me get up and let me facilitate
something really quickly and then let's
move on right to get them to what I want
them to do yes exactly that's awesome
okay so we agreed that this was
something that he wanted to change and
so the idea was you're not going to
facilitate you're going to have someone
else on your team facilitate and you're
going to sit in as a participant you
have a voice but you're one voice of the
team and the first time that we did this
he sat down someone else started
facilitating but you know Darius it just
wasn't moving fast enough and we weren't
getting to the right answer fast enough
and hey we only have 15 minutes of the
meeting left and we need the answer and
so he jumped up ran to the board and
just took over so the good news is that
he tried and he did sit and play a
different role for a period of time
so that's progress
and then we debrief afterward what
happened why did you jump up and take
over and what was the outcome of doing
that delegation requires a shift in
mindset and that's something a coach can
help you with this is something I really
want to dig into because what one coach
told me as far as she needed to embrace
your leadership role and I think what
she was saying is get out of the weeds
and I thought about my like why do I
sometimes like to dive into the weeds
and you know I think the negative
interpretation is because it's easier
right those are technical challenges not
adaptive challenges you know they're
fixable so you can get a little bit of
endorphin rush I fixed this problem I
fix that problem we're moving the ball
we're moving the ball and I get you know
I get a satisfaction out of each
incremental step even though those are
incremental steps off cliff right so I
think part of it is might be you know
psychologically it's nice to solve for
little problems and it's easier to solve
little problems than to think about big
challenges and I think also with
delegation you really have to be
comfortable this is my opinion as a
leader with good enough
because so many Executives say hey I'm
the smartest in the room which means I
need Perfection from any everyone else
and that's not going to work that's not
going to scale I mean when leaders go
through and question and understand that
Viewpoint at the end they say wow this
is actually preventing me from scaling
and so the question I have to them is
what's good enough good enough is not
bad
good enough is good but good enough is
not Perfection but delegation is also a
skill you can practice and Lori has a
method she uses to teach it people think
delegation is a soft skill but it
actually does have an underlying process
that helps you be more successful it's
important to understand that delegation
includes introducing the task
demonstrating clearly what needs to be
done ensuring understanding allocation
of authority information resources
letting go but then monitoring so those
are things that we have to work on
Lori doesn't just work with Founders and
CEOs she's often called upon to help
teams and she's got techniques for that
too all clients come to me I want a high
performing team how do I do that guess
what there's a great framework by
someone called tuckman in the 1960s and
it is the stages of team formation so
hey you don't put people in a room close
the door and say create your team
the idea is the team forms it storms it
norms and then it performs
so you have to go through each of these
stages to get to a high performing team
and what's really fun is whenever I
introduce this framework to even an
existing team that's been working
together for a while I said read this
then write on a piece of paper no one
else will know what stage is the team at
currently and I collect everyone's
pieces of paper and guess what no one
agrees that's fascinating some people
think they're norming some people think
they're storming some people think
they're performing and we don't know
where we are
yet we've been meeting as a team we're
called the senior management team and by
the way we're supposed to take the
company to the next level because that's
our role so let me give you another
example because sometimes I think we
make things too complex
so I was working with a client and he
said most of my senior management team
is new new within six months or less
so guess what we normally do as a leader
we put these people in a room they don't
know each other they've never worked
together
and we say okay go work together as a
team
right
the leader says well we have to get
things done we have kpis we have the
strategy we're going to focus on all
these things and that's going to be the
focus of the meeting and I said let's
try this a different way now I didn't
know these people I was new to the
client at this point and I said we're
going to get in a room
and the first thing we're going to do is
every person is going to give three
successes of the week
because I felt like the environment was
a bit negative to be honest it's very
easy to understand all the problems all
the reasons why problems can't be solved
but there are successes everyone you've
been here not that long positive wins
build positive momentum so everyone went
around here are my three successes next
I said I'd really like everyone to talk
about one challenge that they're
currently facing and they're working on
so that person would State the challenge
then I said I would like every person to
tell this individual that just spoke how
they can support her on this challenge
so then each person went around and said
here's how I can support you on your
challenge so we did that took about an
hour because everyone went through said
I have a challenge and then people would
say here's how I can support
great
changing habits requires practice and
that's especially true for leadership in
organizational culture the next week I
show up I said hey hi how is everyone
guess what guess what we're going to do
today the same thing we did last week
start out successes Challenge and the
leader is looking at me like what are
you doing like are we making any
progress like if we made progress on the
work plan kpis were not even discussing
these we did that for four weeks
why
because the most important thing is to
build the relationships and to
understand the interdependencies and the
synergies between functions and the best
way in my opinion to do that is to start
at the human level it's about supporting
someone when they have challenges it's
about recognizing that we can all be
successful despite the demanding
environment once we have those
relationships then we can talk about
kpis then we can talk about project
plans then we can talk about strategy
but if we don't have the underlying
relationship as individuals and part of
a team how are we going to move forward
in business what I really like about
this exercise that you did is that it's
building relationships but through the
business right so by hearing what other
people value is their success is you're
understanding what motivates them what's
important in their line of the business
right and by offering to to help you're
also expressing empathy and you're
stating out front this is how I'm going
to collaborate and so that breaks down
silos absolutely and I think the point
also is focusing on the kpi is not going
to create the relationship that's just a
layer on top of and so I think you're
right I mean I think we just have to
make sure that we know what success
looks like at the beginning and it's
about the relationship and then to your
point the question is how's the best way
to build that do you find that often the
entrepreneur in their mind they have a
very clear idea of the culture they want
in their workplace the accountability
and all of that and they assume or they
think that that's obvious but it isn't
to their teams very much there's so many
things to your point Darius that go
unsaid
it's just expected they know it's just
expected that we have alignment
but everyone internalizes and interprets
things differently so interestingly
enough I just met with a client
yesterday and we were talking about
values
and one of the things that I've seen
very successful in understanding and
interpreting values is role play because
if you take your team and you put them
into small groups and you say okay we
would like you as a team to role play
this value
and do it in front of everyone
it really requires them to think about
and internalize what does this mean to
me what does it mean to the company and
how do I communicate and act that out
huh you're really making me think now
Lori
[Music]
though it may seem like Lori can fix
anything there are limits to what a
coach can accomplish I think if coaching
as helping someone become a better
leader but what about all the underlying
psychological
baggage that a person might be bringing
there right like to what extent does a
coach start to become a psychotherapist
is that part of the training is that
okay is that what you know it is what it
is so you know the ways in which the
person's childhood or upbringing or
other non-work experiences shape their
personality I'm trying to understand
what's the boundary between I need a
therapist or I need a coach or is a
coach a therapist no the in my
experience I'm not a therapist I'm not
trained as a therapist I'm trained as a
coach so they are different right and it
is important I believe to respect that
they're different I'm really focused on
Work Work behaviors and how you present
yourselves to others at work in a work
situation
while she can't improve your
relationship with your mom Lori does
help clients with the emotional aspects
of running a business after all CEOs
can't just check their feelings at the
door I've heard you use the phrase
before the emotional Runway I know what
a financial Runway is what's an
emotional Runway I'm really glad that
you brought this up because this is such
an important part of being a coach
really it's about the energy and the
passion that you have to continue to
move the business forward because it is
difficult as an entrepreneur there's
always challenges everyone is bringing
you their problems to solve they're
always giving you reasons why something
won't work and so because it's lonely
and because and especially in Emerging
Markets there's so many things outside
of your control
emotional Runway is how much energy do
you have available to move things
forward and address these challenges and
presumably it's a direct function of
your passion for what you're doing or
what problem you're trying to solve with
your business I think that's part of it
and I also think within the business
while you're running the business are
you focused on the things that are most
interesting to you and give you enough
energy so I think it's a combination of
both and as you've probably guessed Lori
has strategies to handle the emotional
aspects of leadership because of course
she does there's a couple things that I
do with clients that maybe I can share
around the emotional Runway because I do
think this is a topic that doesn't get
enough attention with entrepreneurs so
when we do the how I spend my time this
is a great time in the discussion after
the tracking to say what of the things
you are doing drain you and you do not
like to do that's the first thing you
delegate and we talked about how to put
in the process so that the delegation
can be successful the second thing I do
with an entrepreneur is I I think about
and discuss work-life balance or just
time away where you can reflect you can
think and you can see see the forest
from the trees and guess what as a coach
I'm a good accountability partner did
you do that did you take that Wednesday
morning that you committed to yourself
and did you do that and if not why let's
talk about it understand the third thing
I do is these entrepreneurs find ideas
everywhere and when they look at their
strategy and they look at strategic
options the first question I ask is
which one are you most excited about and
that should be a very important filter
in determining what you do as a business
so I imagine then that sometimes the
outcome of coaching is that
the leader is actually in the wrong
place
you know maybe the reason they keep
focusing on this thing that's tangential
to the businesses because that's what
they really love and the rest of it is
actually drawing down on their emotion
like their emotional runways getting
shorter and shorter because
they're not admitting to the fact that
actually that it's this thing over here
that's really gives them life
and all the rest of it's just a drag
absolutely so I'll give you an example
we had a session where this leader this
entrepreneur
went through a strategic plan so much
energy so much opportunity we're gonna
do it let's go go team everything sounds
great
the next week he and I meet he closes
the door and the first thing he says to
me is Lori I can't do this anymore
I should have been gone a year ago
can you imagine that's the starting
point I can't do it anymore
and then covet hits and that's exactly
the time when as a leader you have to
stand up and Lead through a crisis
where's the emotional Runway what's left
and if we've gone through all of those
things and the result is you know what
I'm just not the right person to take it
to the next level that's okay then let's
have that conversation let's put in a
plan to transition out or to move to a
different role and let's be proud that
we're doing that and I think that these
are really important conversations to
have and to normalize we should be proud
of the work we've done and let's have
someone else take a turn at running the
firm that's a good thing to do it's a
very Noble thing to do and so there's no
shame in any of this and I really want
people to understand that there's no
shame in saying this is not for me now
and I've got other things that I'm more
excited about and I can add more value
and a coach can help you work through
the Practical implementations once
you've made mentally that decision that
you need to move on
as you work with a coach you and your
team will develop
this growth might be hard to see from
the inside but a coach can help you
monitor your progress I'm continually
trying to understand what's the progress
the leader is making What's the progress
the team is making are we moving you
know with enough similarity so that this
whole thing can be successful when we
put all these pieces of the puzzle
together and it becomes the company
operating
so how do you make this progress of
coaching sticky this is a great question
you have goals
and you're working towards those goals
but I try to simplify it and just
reflect on have we made progress and has
the progress been consistent because it
does always take longer than you think
it will and you may think you're
starting at step five but you're
actually starting at step one so I think
it's reflecting on the progress not the
end end goal that you may have defined
at the beginning Lori has evidence that
a coach can transform a business
but your coach won't be around forever
right well not necessarily plenty of
clients have engaged coaches for
additional sessions beyond their initial
agreement some have found them so
indispensable that they've invited them
to join their board I think
realistically it's a longer relationship
so clients that I've been working with
for many years are much stronger because
of it
stronger as Leaders stronger financially
better business performance
it always takes longer than you think to
make change so don't wait get a coach
and start working on it then so that you
don't get in a situation where you're
like I should have done this two years
ago
[Music]
as an entrepreneur you're trying to be
the best you can be and theoretically
it's possible to improve without a coach
just like it's possible to learn without
a teacher but why do it the hard way
a coach offers tangible steps to improve
your business and yourself what's more
they give you invaluable perspective to
diagnose your issues as well as
accountability and support along the way
I'd encourage you to try some of the
exercises from this episode I know I
will but that barely scratches the
surface of what a coach has to offer
Lori has something for every business
challenge you could think of and plenty
you haven't so if you want to go fast go
alone but if you want to go far get a
coach
[Music]
I'd like to thank Lori Fuller for
sharing her practice and passion with us
I really will be taking her up on that
free coaching offer I mean Lori I knew
this was gonna you know I was up late
preparing for this thing and then I was
like why am I worried about this this is
going to be awesome
[Laughter]
thank you
this has been grit and growth from the
Stanford Graduate School of Business I'm
your host Darius Teeter if you like this
episode follow us and leave a review on
your favorite podcast app Erica amoakaya
Jay and VN virgin researched and
developed content for this episode
Kendra gladich is our production
coordinator and our executive producer
is Tiffany Steves with writing and
production from Andrew Gannon and sound
design and mixing by Alex Bennett at
lower Street Media thanks for joining us
we'll be back soon with another episode
thank you
foreign